[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
celebrities plead to stop a man's
execution why his former prosecutor says
he does not deserve
death he did not mastermind this he did
not plan on this
and a colorado city fights a civil
rights claim by the family of a man
killed by police
should a wrongful death lawsuit be
dismissed in the elijah maclean case
plus a man strikes a deal in a murder
case then finds himself behind bars
how police rearrested one of the
suspects in the holly bowo case
later the alleged kenosha shooter will
be tried for murder
we break down kyle rittenhouse's
self-defense arguments
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome over to long crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
in a race against time a man convicted
of murdering two youth ministers
wants president trump to spare his life
anget libya is here to tell us about
brandon bernard's plea
and the celebrity support he has in his
corner
yeah brian brandon bernard's death
sentence has been upheld by
every court but now some jurors who were
in his trial and a former prosecutor say
his life should be spared it was a
gruesome
horrific crime in 1999 youth ministers
todd and stacy bagley
were kidnapped robbed shot and their
bodies set on fire
brandon bernard is scheduled to be
executed december 10th
for his role in the crime he was 18 at
the time
one of the things i wanted to do was
contact the baggage family and let them
know
that i felt bad and i wish i could
change things christopher v alva the
shooter was
executed in september reality tv star
kim kardashian who's taken an interest
in criminal justice reform
is supporting bernard's bid for clemency
she tweeted that her fighting for a stay
of execution
does not take away from the sympathy she
feels for the bagleys
and while brandon did participate in
this crime
his role was minor compared to that of
the other teens involved
two of whom are home from prison now
five jurors
are also saying that bernard should now
get life without parole
i just would not want to see
mr bernard who i don't believe had any
any intention of killing anyone
have to die for this
now one of the jurors said that he voted
for death because they were told at
trial
that stacey bagley was unconscious at
the time that the car was set on fire
but a defense expert is now saying that
bagley was medically dead
from the gunshot wound to her head an
assistant u.s attorney who fought to
uphold
that conviction on appeal now says that
brandon bernard's life
it should be spared and he should get
life without parole
this idea that he provided the gun and
he knew this killing was going to happen
that's not true
they got this gun because it was bigger
and they thought it would be scarier
they were going to rob
someone in a parking lot that was their
plan
he had no idea a killing was going to
happen
he had no idea and reading the testimony
also
no one says he lit the car on fire
now an investigator on bernard's defense
team says he was actually called into
the crime
later after the robbery had taken place
because the others involved needed a
ride she says
an accomplice actually told bernard to
set that car on fire
once the bagleys were dead
brandon is just not the same person he
was when he was 18.
he's 40 years old now he was a scared
and insecure teenager
who due to his home life was looking for
um support and and um
male support and male guidance and ended
up being friends with
individuals who also participated in the
crime
brandon bernard has two daughters and
he's done a lot to
help other people young people while
he's been in prison
and on death row in terre haute indiana
brian
mr internet we're hearing from the
prosecutor and the investigator but what
does the bagley family say about this
well i actually reached out to todd
bagley's mother
and she told me she did not want to give
a statement but after christopher v alva
was executed back in september
she issued a statement to a tv station
in indiana and she said that todd and
stacey were two young people who were
deceived
and begged for their lives over several
hours and actually
quoted scripture and the hope that their
kidnappers would let them go
so you can tell she doesn't have any
regret about these death sentences and i
should also mention we reached out to
the white house to see whether or not
president trump is actually going to
consider
issuing a commutation and i have not
heard back yet from
the white house press office brian with
december 10th right around the corner
we'll keep eyes on that case thank you
very much anjanet
terry as i'm looking at this case i
think anjanet hit what i thought was the
strongest argument
that in the previous case they believed
that the smoke inhalation
killed the victim now they're saying it
didn't could that fact alone
be a reason to stop the the death
penalty here
well it is a serious factor brian and i
think that you have to think about that
as far as the death penalty is concerned
the other issue here is we should only
impose the death penalty
under very strict circumstances and if
in fact he wasn't the one to do
any fatal blows he was 18 at the time i
think we should think about
life in prison without parole which is
a very harsh sentence in and of itself
yeah we'll definitely keep eyes on that
because if that information can reach
the court maybe not just the president
could stop this but maybe the governor
or
other federal courts could pause this if
that new information as to how the
victim died
gets to them in time thank you terry a
suspect is dead and three law
enforcement officers are injured
after the execution of a warrant ended
in a shootout the massachusetts state
police say they were moving to arrest a
suspect
wanted for wounding a state trooper
investigators tracked andre sterling to
an apartment in the bronx new york
they say there was an exchange of fire
two u.s marshals were shot an nypd
detective wounded
and the suspect shot dead and now to
terry austin who has some animal news
for us
right brian mann's best friend is being
credited with helping
officers find a missing elderly man an
off-duty officer out hunting in
manchester new jersey
spotted the dog on a trail sergeant
charles brooks
followed petty paw's print for several
hundred feet
he found petty's owner a 78 year old man
who had been reported missing hours
earlier
police say the man had crashed his
vehicle and became disoriented
brooks was able to navigate officers to
their location to safely rescue
the man and in florida
a volunteer at carol baskin's big cat
rescue
ranch was bitten by a tiger the
organization says
candy cosier opened a gate
at a feeding time without a
coordinator to help kemba the tiger
grabbed her
arm and nearly tore it off at the
shoulder baskin is known for her role
in the netflix series tiger king the
incident happened the same day the u.s
house passed
the big cat public's safety act which
bans most
big cat ownership brian and based on
those two stories that's why i'm a dog
person and not a cat person thanks terry
still ahead on law and crime daily a
sheriff calls a plea agreement quote
a deal with the devil how a man talked
his way out of a long prison sentence
wound up back in jail
but first we speak with the attorney for
the family of elijah mclean
why city officials are asking a judge to
dismiss their claim
after the break
[Music]
we turn to colorado where the city of
aurora is asking a judge
to dismiss a case brought by the family
of elijah mclean elijah mcclain died
last year after being placed in a choke
hold by officers
then sedated by paramedics police say a
person
had made a report saying that he looked
sketchy his family filed a federal civil
rights lawsuit against the city
police and fire department the suit
claims fares to train
excessive force racially biased policing
and
inadequate medical care led to mclean's
death
police body cam video captured when
paramedics administered
500 milligrams of ketamine to sedate him
joining me now is mari newman an
attorney who represents the mclean
family
mari thanks for joining us thank you for
having me
of course mari in a motion filed by the
attorneys for the fire
rescue employees they claim the ketamine
was not an
overdose what's your response to that
claim
well from a legal standpoint they
shouldn't have been administering
any ketamine whatsoever because elijah
mclean
was not suffering from any kind of a
medical problem that required medical
treatment
he was an absolutely innocent young man
just walking home from the corner store
when he was stopped by police grabbed
thrown to the ground
they did two carotid choke holds um
administered
various kinds of other types of
excessive force against him
and then ultimately these medics gave
him a massive dose of ketamine
not one drop of ketamine was medically
required
and certainly not a 500 milligram dose
for a guy
that was about 140 pounds yeah that was
one of the major things that caught my
eye when the story
first came out totally gutted me and
broke my heart they talked about the
size of elijah mcclane compared to the
amount of ketamine put in his body
can you kind of talk to us about that
sure
well so ketamine is a drug that has been
used for what
is called excited delirium that's a
medical condition and i'm using air
quotes as i say that
because it's actually not recognized by
many
um different organizations the american
medical association doesn't even
recognize it
but um what you hear about is these
circumstances when law enforcement kills
somebody
and then later they try to justify it by
saying that that person was suffering
from so-called
excited delirium but in any event elijah
mclean wasn't
uh exhibiting any of the symptoms that
are associated with it
he did not have supernatural strength as
you can see from the video
he is completely restrained under a pile
of law enforcement officers
by the testimony of the officers about
700 pounds worth of cops were on top of
this 140 pound man
who was begging for his life and saying
that he couldn't breathe
so he certainly didn't exhibit that he
was
responding appropriately he was
identifying himself
he was saying his name that he was
trying to go home
that he hadn't done anything wrong that
he didn't have a weapon
and they still administered this drug
which was
medically totally inappropriate and that
was a constitutional violation of his
right to bodily integrity we cannot
legally be
given medication against our will and
that's what happened here
yeah i i tend to agree with you mari i
don't practice in colorado i practice in
brooklyn but even in brooklyn
what an officer did to elijah mclean you
just can't do that
it doesn't make sense to me from a state
or federal background
mari thank you so much for joining us
today i wish you the best of luck in
your claim going forward
thank you so much for having me and i'm
happy to come back anytime
i'll hold you to that coming up on law
and crime daily kenosha shooting suspect
kyle renthouse appears remotely for
court
what prosecutors and his defense are
saying plus
police nab a man convicted in a murder
case just months after being released
from prison
that case and more when we return
the man released from prison after
admitting to his role
in the killing of a young tennessee
woman nearly 10 years ago
is back behind bars jason autry
testified that two other men
killed holly bobo in the spring of 2011.
for his testimony
acha received an eight-year sentence in
a plea deal the local sheriff described
as a deal with the devil audrey was
rearrested after a
deputy spotted him in a field with a gun
the deputy reportedly found
meth and ammunition on him
holly bobo disappeared from her family
home in 2011
hunters discovered some of her remains
three years later
john dylan adams pled guilty and
co-defendant jason autry testified
against zach adams
at trial what are your expectations
you know what i mean by that for
testifying here today
what do you what do you think's going to
happen i'm hoping for leniency
he asked me would i help him bury the
body
and i said yeah i said i will i brought
the upper torso
to the end of the tailgate where he
grabbed the legs
and i set the head the upper end on the
rip-rap pile
i told him i said he's still alive out
of the floorboard of pickup
he pulls a pistol i looked around and i
told him
there was nothing coming close is clear
something to that
to that effect and at that time
boom the gun sign gun went out
and it sounded like boom boom boom
underneath that bridge was just one shot
but it echoed underneath that bridge all
the way down that damn river bottom
terry please say they believe autry was
kind of getting high in his own supply
when they found him
and with the past conviction he's now
facing up to 20 years behind bars
how is his previous conviction going to
affect this new case
well you know brian we have to think
about whether or not it's even going to
come
into evidence so the judge is going to
have to consider
why is it being introduced it can't be
used for motive here because they're
two totally unrelated crimes and
actually it
can't really be used for anything else
because
i think any other argument is going to
be you know
a failure because the credibility of the
witnesses
really has nothing to do with this
particular crime so
i think it's not even going to get into
evidence if you ask me and as far as
sentencing is concerned
i think the prior convictions is a
felony conviction i think that
will affect sentencing and i think he
will get
a higher sentence as far as that's
concerned
now of course the family had to agree to
that plea deal what do you think their
thoughts are now that he's rearrested
yeah i think they're probably thinking
that that plea deal
is not a good idea considering the fact
that he's out there
that he's got these other issues going
on you know he may have weapons and
drugs et cetera he could commit another
crime so they're probably thinking
he should have stayed behind bars all
right thank you for that terry
when we come back kyle renthouse is
bound for trial
the accused kenosha shooter motion to
dismiss charges
was denied how the case progresses next
the kenosha shooting suspect is bound
for trial after a judge ruled there was
probable cause he committed a crime
kyle written house is accused of fatally
shooting two people
and wounding a third during protests in
august rinhouse was released from jail
on a two million dollar bond his defense
was denied their emotion
and to dismiss two of the six charges
against him
the lead investigator described the
shootings at the probable cause hearing
there was a call at 6226 sheridan road
which is a car source business where
shots were fired
investigation later determined that
joseph rosenbaum
was shot in that parking lot and later
determined to be deceased
then then kyle rittenhouse was the
shooter in that incident uh he then fled
that scene
as he was running northbound there was a
crowd chasing after him
he ends up stumbling in the roadway
after being struck in the head
when he's on the ground a subject
attempts to kick him in the head
he then fired two rounds in the air
towards that subject
missing another subject approached him
with a skateboard
and another shot was fired that subject
was identified as anthony huber
that gunshot subsequently killed him a
another subject approached
kyle identified as gage grosskroots uh
they had kind of a uh a moment at which
point
uh kyle fired one time striking him in
the right bicep
uh kyle's unable to get up and get away
from that scene
cross the defense asked the detective
about victim joseph
rosenbaum wearing a face mask at the
time of the shooting
it's a crime in wisconsin to commit a
crime while masked correct
you and i objected to relevance of this
question it goes to the events
in question the state is trying to put
forth a one-sided
stilted view of what happened protecting
someone
who doesn't deserve protection of the
state he's admast
robber okay uh this is preliminary
hearing i'm going to sustain the
objection
and uh for purposes of preliminary
hearing that's outside the scope it's
not relevant for these purposes
mr richard mr rosenbaum is not wearing
his shirt in exhibit three correct
without wearing it traditionally he's
wearing it around his face
correct correct
the defense continued to assert a
self-defense theory while
cross-examining the lead detective
individuals in this video at
approximately nine o'clock twelve
o'clock
and three o'clock which are approaching
my client he points the firearm at them
but does not shoot correct
yes sir and he gets up
and he goes to turn himself into law
enforcement with his hands up correct
correct did you ever see kyle act
inappropriate towards somebody
who was not threatening him with a
firearm
objection relevance again i'm going to
say
i just doesn't want to hear the truth
uh mr richards here's the key you have
an opportunity at trial but we're here
at preliminary hearing i understand
perhaps you're frustrated but perhaps we
continue the examination
in the video before my client is knocked
to the ground by the strike to the head
you hear numerous individuals
yelling kill him get him cranium
him correct correct so
terry i get that this figure kyle ryden
house is very polarizing but the one
thing that
disgusts me a little is poor poor
defense attorneys
it's like a poker game and he's showing
his entire hand these are
trial arguments not probable cause
hearing arguments
am i wrong here is he messing up left
right and center
oh you're 100 right brian and even the
judge agrees with you
the judge actually said you know this is
just a preliminary hearing this is
not the trial i know you might be
frustrated but this is not the time
to ask those types of questions and to
present that type of evidence so
you do risk tipping your hand at trial
if you do
all of this information at the
preliminary stage so i agree with you
on the other hand i will say i think
everybody kind of knew
that the defense was going to be
self-defense but you know
don't show your entire hand at the
preliminary hearing
yeah we all know it's self-defense but
what details the fact that the person
is wearing a shirt on his head and
you're gonna call him a robber that's
something you spring on the prosecutors
do you think he has any tricks up his
sleeve
left for the trial or have the
prosecutors maybe figure it all out by
now
yeah i don't think he has much left
because he is doing this sort of
detailed
questioning that will let the
prosecution know
what direction the defense is heading in
so i think for him to do this when
as you said you know brian the standard
is a very low bar for a probable cause
hearing there was no reason for him
to ask these extended questions so i i
do think that
it was a mistake and that maybe he was
you know showboating
yeah this is a place i think you've got
to lose the battle but win the war
thank you very much for joining us as
always terry and thanks for you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you